tell me tell me this then out David blog
it'll do won't it tell me do you think I
mean a very serious issue this I mean do
you think that mr. Corbyn could' and
should be embarrassed by these fifty or
so Labour MPs well I think we should
take Jeremy at his word and his word is
that this is new politics that he's much
more relaxed and leaders have been in
the past he will know of course that
there will be dissenters on the
conservative benches so there's going to
be a difference of opinion in both major
parties when the vote comes on so should
it come on Syria and what the terms are
of what David Cameron intends to to
promote you see last time when we voted
there was no game plan there was no
answer to the question and what next in
other words where are we going from here
and I think that's what David Cameron
will have to answer and it is down to
the government of course I mean the
opposition have a clear responsibility
to act responsibly but the government
absolute imperative to lead but I mean
you all as we would expect incredibly
well informed on the the issues here do
you think there there are grounds that
could be put forward by the governments
that Labour should support for British
action in Syria against is yes I think
there's a now an overwhelming case that
if we are assisting in Iraq to deal with
Isis and their main bases in Syria and
the Russians are taking action in
relation to the Assad regime then why we
shouldn't join the Americans is a
mystery to me because we should be
saying we're dealing with a common enemy
we're dealing with them on both sides of
the border okay the Iraqi government
invited us to help from Iraqi soil but
this is not a war with a clear border
this is this is a war which is about
saving people from the genocide and the
horrors of what ISIL is actually
promoting so we've got a we've got a I
would have thought a clearer
understanding of what we need to do
terms of engagement are a different
matter I think those need to be debated
and spelt out much more clearly in what
circumstances we use our the RAF and how
we deal with the the backup services
that go with it but from Labour's point
of view I mean you'll understand and you
know better than the many that of course
this generation of the Labour Party
escort scarred by the actions of of your
generation in particular voting to join
George W Bush in actions against Iraq in
2003 labour never wants to go through
that again well I think we were scarred
originally by not taking action in
Rwanda in 1994 we then eventually took
action in Southeast Europe in terms of
what was happening in Bosnia and against
Serbia we claimed and we keep
pronouncing we're scarred by what
happened in 2003 obviously with what we
know 12 years on and the circumstances
now we might have voted differently I
would vote exactly the same again given
the knowledge I had at that time with
the arguments at that time with the
belligerence of Saddam Hussein at that
time however let's be clear many of the
new MPs who thankfully did get elected
on May the 7th and in my own experience
campaigning around the country for the
in the election people were not raising
Iraq this is an internal labor party
argument and whilst a lot of the new
members who have joined and those who
joined to vote were interested and if
you like were committed against taking
any kind of military action outside this
country in the future many other people
across the country are not and I think
we just need to distinguish and I think
it's a challenge for not just Labour MPs
but for Labour Party members now are we
actually saying that we would never take
action outside this country again unless
our country itself was directly under
fire because if we are saying that then
that's adjusted policy in a way that we
haven't seen since the arguments before
the first world war and can I just ask
you mr. Blanc it's about you
all view of our mr corbyn's doing I mean
it goes to me that isn't that a a part
of you of a man who used to run there
via the Socialist Republic of South
Yorkshire I know you didn't term it that
but it's in the HERA it's there a part
of you that quite likes the cut of his
jib that likes some of the things he's
saying and the way he's doing it well if
we hadn't gone through what we went
through 35 years ago there's no doubt
that I would have had a great deal more
sympathy in other words if we hadn't
already run this course and been down it
and seen the consequences then quite
legitimately people could say well let's
let's have a go
actually I think times have moved on
we're dealing with modernity we're
dealing with the challenge of ever rapid
more globalization we're dealing with
issues around where power lies across
the world and how we use States craft to
actually deal with that to mobilize the
forces of consumers in boycotting the
transnational companies that don't pay
taxes here that's the kind of agenda I
think that Jeremy should be pursuing
rather than the old-fashioned let's
nationalize let's centralize let's
pretend we can do things from the
benches in Westminster whether they in
the Commons or in the Lord's and frankly
that would be a new sort of politics I
hope Jeremy because we've still got to
find out for weeks on precisely what the
cut of his jib actually is to be honest
with you I'd hope that Jeremy will
develop that new politics but I also
hope that it will be the open politics
that he's preached because we don't want
organisations setting up like momentum
that's been established this week being
a party within a party and I think
that's the challenge for Jeremy Corbyn
if you mean it Jeremy then practice it
and you think do you think it's an issue
if he goes to see the Queen or not to
join the the Privy Council is a bit of a
storm in a teacup well I think I think
people made this point before it's
sometimes the way you do things and not
necessarily what you do I don't there
was a real problem at all I mean not
going to take the oath at this moment in
time it might have been phased and
phrased more carefully
I remember in 2005 when we won the
election I was back in cabinet I had to
go to take the oath to take the new
Secretary of State's job at Work and
Pensions
and I couldn't go the first weekend so I
went a couple of weeks later I don't
think anybody made a fuss about that
then and I honestly think that we need
to get on with debating the big issues
around which policies the labor parties
are deering to what our offer will be in
four years time what kind of Britain we
want to see and above all are we in the
real world of modernity or are we still
anchoring after a nostalgia of the past
which sadly for some of us has long gone